so I think uh I would like to first show
you basically the end results so like
how what's the how far you could get if
you can actually uh do the thing that I
promised so building interactive
animated reports so this is a stream L
app uh I I hope many of you recognizes
it from the design and there's the
there's an IPI visu chart in the center
uh you can recognize it from the VIS
logo in the bottom right corner of it
and basically it's an interactive chart
so the user can just extend the time
frame this is actually uh how much
revenue different music form is
generated in the US and and you can
change the the time frame you can uh
adjust the the values for inflation uh
you can uh switch from revenue to volume
using these streamlit vigs or controls
that that are that are put here you can
uh just aggregate all the values by
format uh you can add more formats uh
you can either with this buttons or you
can select some uh like uh with this so
you can we can just remove the tape data
and it and it goes away and we can also
sort these by by value so as you can see
uh a user without any knowledge of
python or streamlet a business user even
could just come here and generate some
views for their own uh and because of
the animated way these views are being
connected it's uh at least we hope is a
lot easier to to follow along uh and
understand what they just changed and
also in the background uh there's like
an animated story being created so if I
click on this download story button
uh then uh then an HTML file is being
downloaded to my computer and uh and if
I I mean this is just a very early
implementation of this feature here but
if I open it then I have actually an
animated presentation that contains all
the different steps that I took uh while
I was uh fiddling with the report so as
you can see I just extended the time
frame to the right I removed some years
from the left I adjusted the values for
inflation then switched to volume and
then aggregated everything uh over on
the uh so like independently from the
year and so you have these controls uh
beneath the chart by which you can or
anybody basically can control the
animation this is an HTML file that you
can send over in an email and some and
anything like that and you can actually
even seek the animation yourself so you
can you can seek it like this and uh and
and and and make it really easy for
anyone to understand what changed from
one view to the other uh so yeah that's
like uh the most complete form of uh of
using streamlit and visu together and
and I just wanted to give you this very
quick uh overview of of what's possible
and then I'm going to now just dig
deeper into how it's being made and and
how you can build similar tools similar
stories and reports on your own uh and
um there are two things I wanted to
mention before I dig deeper first one is
I'm going to have uh together with uh
with Zachary Blackwood from streamlit uh
90minut tutorial on all this so uh this
is going to be my talk will be a quick
overview of everything being used here
and then uh from um from from uh I think
uh yeah so like three hours from now uh
we are going to have uh the 90-minute
tutorial where we will just teach you uh
the the the ropes of all this and and by
the end of that session you will be able
to start building your first interactive
animated data stories but also uh
interactive animated reports within
streamlet using IPI visu so I would
encourage you to to just uh uh join that
session too and there's also one other
thing so everything we do is free and
open source and as you can imagine we we
always uh try to keep on understanding U
what is going on and and uh and how our
tools and our technology is being
perceived so I will share you a link uh
to a a survey uh a form that I would
really like to ask you to feel towards
the end of the the session maybe during
the Q&A which I would definitely want to
leave some time for uh because your
feedback helps us a lot in understanding
uh how to move forward and and how what
we built is is being perceived so thanks
in advance if you take the time and and
fill that survey so vizu the that I'm
representing uh very shortly we built a
generic chart Morpher so we have an
engine that can generate all different
types of charts and can seamlessly
animate between them it's more flexible
than any similar data visualization
technology out there and the reason for
that is that we use a single logic uh to
generate different types of charts and
because of the single logic we can just
interpolate between the charts that are
generated on our engines interface uh
this is a novel approach we to work
quite surprised that nobody else uh
tried to build charts this way but we're
happy that we're our technology is quite
unique in this sense and uh you know the
next uh logical question would be why we
build such an engine and so we're
actually working towards this vision of
um building uh animated uh so like a new
graphical user interface for data in
general and we think that such a
flexible data visualization or data
morphing engine that we have would be
the Cornerstone the the central element
of of such a graphical user interface
that would enable people with uh with
with like end users not experts like
yourself but mostly um you know basic
business users uh to to analyze data to
build animated stories to to reuse the
the insights that they found on reports
and dashboards or to even use them for
forecasting and planning uh and and
that's what we're working towards so the
animation bit and and we initially we
focused on storage telling actually
because that's where the the use case
and the benefits of the animated data
visualization technology that we have
were most apparent so um why we focus on
animation I mean very briefly uh
animation helps people understand uh
different views of the same data set
basically and a connection between these
different views different charts so here
are four charts showing the same data
but the the the the relationship between
those might not be obvious especially
for non experts whereas if I connect
these views with the use of Animation uh
everything becomes very clear so it's U
no further explanation is necessary
basically um and that uh saves a lot of
bandwidth I mean mental bandwidth for
people uh looking at uh at a chart or a
story uh because it's just yeah so much
much easier to to understand what's
going on there uh also like a couple of
very basic examples you can do uh drill
down uh analytics or like you know show
uh the the relationship between a
composite index and its components a
different way again without further
explanation being necessary uh you can
show uh the components of a stack chart
and and just show it very easily if if a
component goes against a trend again for
with the members of the audience being
crystal clear about what you're about to
say here uh you can uh just switch
between uh U Aggregates and and
distribution over time like we did with
the within the streamlet app um you can
uh show change over time so the
animation basically gives you a new
dimension uh to to chart uh to use on
your charts which is time itself um and
and then you can build these uh kind of
racing bar charts that were so popular
at one point that they were banned from
the data's beautiful subreddit um and
also you can just turn one chart into a
whole narrative into a whole story this
one about uh mobile phone providers and
and initially with the pie chart we just
sold the number of phones they produce
but by adding the the the profit that
they're making uh we can actually see
here that there are these leagues of
companies uh that generate very
different amounts of money from
producing basically the same or very
similar products and uh we have also a
sense of magnitude uh between these
companies like apple is how dominant
apple and and Samsung is compared to
everybody else um so something about our
technology the engine that I mentioned
to you is written in C++ uh we used it
in house when it was ready we built
storage and interactives partly for the
dat's beautiful subredit where they got
really really popular so we gaed over
200,000 uploades and 20 million views
there with only a handful of stories
then in September
21 we released our JavaScript open
source JavaScript library for developers
and uh after that we we turned our
attention to data scientists and uh so
ipiv visu is out there being an open
source charting tool since uh March 2022
and we added the storytelling bit that
basically just puts these uh buttons
under your charts that I showed in the
um first example by which you can build
present and share or like present your
data stories and and an IP story is Al
again an open source Tool uh that you
can install from pip oronda uh to to a
lot of different types of notebooks and
other tools and and you can build
present and share interactive animated
data stories with that and the open
source uh approach gave us a lot of uh
integration opportunities that were uh
mostly done by members of the community
for whom we are very grateful for and
then actually streamlet is is a great
example of that so Zachary who I'm going
to have the tutorial with in uh two
hours and 48 minutes uh was the one
actually who integrated streamlit with
IP visu and created a bidirectional
component that I'm just going to yeah
give you uh some examples of so without
further Ado let's get down to coding I
prepped some materials for you to make
it easier for you to follow along you
can either resit this uh with using the
bitly link bit.i slvu hyen pyata hyen
Global or just use the QR code that's
now on the screen uh it will uh uh like
redirect you to this uh yeah sorry I
don't have it here let me quickly bring
it up uh but you you should arrive at a
GitHub folder within the visu workshops
uh repository uh called Pata Global uh
where you will be met with a friendly
welcome note and a ton of useful links
um like I think the most important ones
are these two apps that I'm going to
show you and uh then there are a couple
of ideas on how you could start
individual work uh and I think also very
importantly uh to the very btom there's
like a slack link uh if you click on
that you'll join our our slack Channel
where you'll meet with fellow visu users
and and you know all of us from the visu
team so I would encourage you very
strongly to to join our slack if you
start using our tools because um it's
just better to start learning something
new in a in a community and we have a
very supportive Community actually and
and within this repo folder you have a
couple of subfolders So within the
notebook subfolder uh you will find U
seven notebooks in total I will only
show you the first one right now but uh
you have a chance to have gain deeper
understanding of how IPI visu works and
I also prepped some sort of
playground notebooks with with some
suggestions within there how you could
get an gain an understanding into the
logic and the the the syntax and the
code structure of ipiv visu so I'm going
to first show you this first notebook
this is already here here uh let me see
if I no I'm just going to restart it
because uh I didn't have the time to um
to to remove everything and I just want
to show you the the bits and pieces one
by one so the only thing you have to
understand right now about IPI visu is
that it has a I mean you can install it
again by using pip oronda and then there
is a single method called the animate
method that you will use from this uh
this package uh and you call it once uh
with the right parameters you will get
to a static chart and then if you call
it once again that on the same chart
object uh it will turn that chart into
another one in an animated fashion so
you don't have to deal with the
animation bit that's something we do in
the background let me really quickly run
this one while we're talking so that it
loads the data uh the the animate method
has actually three uh arcs uh so you
have to add the data to your chart uh we
are working with panda data frame right
now and uh so it's it's really easy to
to start using it I believe uh there's
the configuration bit where you say how
your chart should look like and then
there's the styling bit uh you know to
to uh adjust the look and feel of your
charts you also have the opportunity to
fiddle with the animation options uh we
we try to make it so that you don't have
to but there are certain cases like for
example when you have a racing bar chart
and you want to really speed up uh the
the transition between one slide to the
other or one state to the other uh that
you you want to just you know make it
really quick and it's all about like you
you decrease the duration of the
animation to 0.1 seconds and there you
go so let me show you a really quick
example of how this whole thing works so
I I haven't installed iPad ISU because
it's already on my system but this is
how you could get started and then we
import pandas and from ipiv visu we
basically import the chart object and
the three other objects that I mentioned
to you we read the CSV file that's
actually the Titanic data set with an
additional column of count here uh and
and and we we say that the P class is a
string so that IU won't think that this
is a value such as the age or the yeah
actually passenger ID I think should
also be um used as a string and then we
create an empty data object here and
call the add DF method of that data
object and just add the data frame to it
so basically now we have a visu act by
visu data object with the data frame
being loaded into it and now we're going
to uh just create a um an empty chart
object for which we set the width and
height for and animate uh like call the
animate method just with the data object
so you don't have to have all
the all the three components all the
three objects but it only creates an
empty chart because you know there's
nothing to show here we just added the
data there and basically we create the
first chart around here when we once
again call the animate method and and
use the config bit where we add the the
count so the number of pass passengers
basically to the x-axis and the sex of
the passengers to the Y AIS and we also
add the counts number of passengers on
the label and and add a title to the
chart and if I run this like this is the
static chart that I mentioned to you
that appears right away as you can see
uh because we added uh the count on the
labels the number here also appears on
the markers and we automatically
aggregated the count values so it was
like one per each row but ipu
automatically summ them up we have all
different like additional aggregation
Logics like main Max and mean so you can
but by default we're we're summing uh
the values that are being put there and
if I add another category the survived
which shows whether the passenger
survived the crash or died in it and add
it also on the color scale then we get
to a stacked bark chart where uh the
people died and survived Reed a
different color and also again
automattic ially the number the count
value is being aggregated and and shown
on the chart and as you can see the
position of the label changed so instead
of being written on the right side of
the bars which is okay for a normal bar
chart they are now written within
beneath so like in the center of the
markers the little rectangles um that
represent the data because you know we
always try to automatically adapt uh to
the the chart being shown and and use
data visualization best practices in
every case uh and now just one uh like a
couple of additional examples here and
first I'm going to comment out these
lines here is U if I remove the survive
from the x-axis as you can see it's h
sorry
uh yeah it's actually it changed no
sorry yeah that's this is how this
should look like I think I fiddled with
it the last time I did so if I remove
the survives uh from the x-axis and
leave only count there and add survive
to the sex where where it was uh just
like next to it then we get to a grouped
chart as as easy as that and as you can
see I forgot to comment out the styling
uh so I also automatically changed the
color palette to use different colors
for died and survived then the default
ones that were you know blue and uh and
and and green so the the the red and
green uh green is is a better fit and
and there are a ton of other things I
can change so I can just uh turn these
rectangles into circles uh no sorry
yeah like this and then I can just since
these are circles I can add the same
value the count to the size of these uh
and then I can switch the coordinate
system to um to Polar like this and then
we end up with a chart that no one
understands so that's that's yeah I mean
that's the downside of having a a
generic charting uh engine that you can
actually create charts that don't make
sense this one is it's a it's a sort of
like a lollipop chart it's pretty
readable with the polar coordinates it
won't be uh so yeah that happens and and
you also have the opportunity to filter
the data being shown so right now we're
going to only leave the markers or
representing people who were uh traveled
on on first class and as you can see
that again changes uh everything in an
animated fashion so that was that would
have been The quick summary of how this
thing works and once again I can tell
you how important it is that you will
have a chance to dig deeper in the
tutorial that that starts uh roughly
three and a half hours from now uh in
order to make it easier for you to start
we have actually an integration with
streamlet this app called the visu
Builder app uh so you don't have to
start learning this uh quite abstract
syntax because we understood that it
might be a little too hard for people uh
which is which makes perfect sense and
so now the with the if you go to visu
hyen Builder the streamlet app this is
where you'll end up with you can use
sample data or or use your own CSV file
and then um yeah you can set what
columns or categories and values because
those are important but not for now and
then you have the chance to add filters
but basically here you can configure
your chart so I'm going to just add year
and yeah let's see quarter and then I'm
going to just add the item sold and uh
and the aggregation logic should be sum
and I just click on create charts and
this app and it it's a little slow
because there are a lot of things
happening and my screen is being shared
and there are a lot of things happening
on the front end you can get these error
messages but they will disappear and and
you basically end up with uh uh list of
charts uh that are being generated so
the different options to create visu
charts using these two categories the
year and the quarter and the single
value the items count and uh for all of
these charts you have the option to to
check out the code for and copy and P
and if you copy and paste it to a
notebook uh it will it will work by
default you might need to update the uh
the reference to the data but that's the
only thing you need to change for them
to work but you can also just add them
to a story so if I click on a couple of
these and again something is happening
in the background which can be quite
slow but but it it works very well so uh
clicked on this uh charts at at chart to
story and then this one and so right in
the in the bottom of the whole thing
what you have is is again an animated
data story that you created just by
clicking around uh which contains all
the charts that you uh clicked on you
add it to the story and you can you have
the opportunity to download that story
similarly to how I showed in the
beginning but also to see the code so we
think it's it's an easier way to so here
here is like one slide and then the code
for that slide and again the code for
the next slide and the next slide so we
think that it's it's a lot easier to get
started with with ipy visu uh using this
builder app and also if you go to the
intro to visu in Streamlight app then
you will have a lot of examples uh into
adding interactivity so actually
utilizing this integration the
bidirectional component that Zachary
built here is like a super simple
example where I can just click on Swap
and and the the category and the value
on the axis are being swapped or here's
another very simple example where with
the slider it's again the music data
that I showed in the beginning so you
have the chance to the user has the
chance to just change the year and then
uh it the the the chart here adapts to
it you would be surprised how easy it is
to to to to do this I mean I I'll try
and really quickly because I I didn't
have the time to to pick it up uh and
now I'm on yeah on Uncharted territories
so yeah let's
[Music]
um yeah here we go so this is the code
uh for that uh specific chart the slider
as you can see we have here a visu chart
uh it's basically the same thing we have
the slider that sets the year value and
then the only thing we have here is just
in one animate method where the filter
is being set dynamically based on the
year value we have one grouped bar chart
we're using the group bar preset here
not just a simple config bit and then
some styling and then that's it so we we
we fill here with the animation options
so to to make the make it quicker uh but
but that's it so it's like 50 lines of
code uh
including importing the packages and
you'll end up with with an app like this
so uh yeah very quickly this is what I
wanted to show you there are a lot of
other things uh because of the B
directionality you can even build
reports like this one where I just so
again it's the music revenues over years
and and I can just click yeah we have
the nice tool tip but you can also just
click on one element and we will just
drill down into that year and then see
it uh like what it contains and then if
I click anywhere else we go back to the
original view so you can add indirect it
in a very intuitive fashion and there
are other ways we we work with the
editable data frame and there are a lot
of other examples you can always Fork
the app and and create your own again I
I would encourage you to to visit or or
check out the recording of the tutorial
we will have it Zachary so you will have
a much better understanding of what's
going on here and now I come to the bit
that I mentioned in the beginning so
that I would really love to ask you to
give me feedback give us feedback it's
at bit.
lvu feedback and also you can use this
QR code it would take like two three
minutes of your time to answer all the
questions uh I would be very glad if you
could do that for us and in the meantime
uh yeah I'll just keep it here for under
15 seconds uh in the meantime we will
just uh since I only have uh four
minutes left um I would like to ask you
to to start filling out the form but
also I will stop sharing my screen and
get back to uh air meet and and and
listen to any questions you might have
um yeah that's it thank you so much
petaz um I am looking at some questions
um from Tina is that is this I think
it's about how much are all the
functionalities open
source I think I can see the questions
uh in the uh no I can't sorry
sorry so what was the question because
it's really hard to hear you honestly uh
sorry um are all this functionality open
source from Dina right yeah okay so yes
all the functionality is open source
free and open source and it will remain
that way we are now working on uh
building an end user SAS tool so
something that a no code tool that
people can use uh without the expertise
that you all have but um but we will
keep the open source bit because we
think that it's really important for us
uh to to have the to keep the open
source Foundation of our technology and
and to to get the feedback and the
expertise of of users like you but
everything I showed today is open
source and thanks for all the positive
comments on the in within the chat and
again thanks if you have the time to to
fill out the the
form um
um wow we have have a ton of people here
that's so
great um does anybody have any other
questions uh we I received a heart from
Dina I believe I'm not sure but
thanks um and and yeah again you can
also watch because I know we are in
parallel with the keynote uh I mean the
tutorial session with Zachary so I I
totally understand if you decide to
watch the keynote and and watch the
recording of the tutorial it might be
even better to join the tutorial because
then we would have the chance to
interact live with me with Zachary and
then you might be able to catch up with
the keynote later on because I guess
that's not as interactive as our session
would be uh so it might be even better
to to join our session and then rewatch
The keynote because I believe all the uh
the recordings of all the sessions are
made available right after uh the the
session and uh yeah just yes yeah so the
recording will be available as soon as
the air time is able to process them so
it shouldn't be long um so thank you so
much for your talk I believe this uh can
you uh will you be publishing these
slides on the Discord or you would
rather yeah that's okay it's it's the
the slides are actually quite uh huge
but but I I can try uh maybe I'll uh
because yeah you know
I think uh you can just leave a link
about your data project on the
Discord there any question cool and if
there are any questions after this
please feel free are you available on
Discord to just answer questions
about yeah sure
absolutely okay uh thanks again for
having me uh I can't wait to to do the
tutorial two and a half hours from now
and uh wish you all the best have a
great P Global Experience